[Music]
well as you know I'm a bear icon bears
are big hairy dudes the gay guys like
okay and I am that my friend it was
recently brought to my attention that I
am such a bear icon my friend will
actually who wrote fifty-fifty sent this
to me he told me that I'm amused in the
creative community of the bear loving
world people in the bear community who
are artists use you as their inspiration
one guy used me as the centerpiece for a
book that he made and it's all about
what a wonderful bear icon I am this is
real that's real I call that one lazy
Sunday that one jazz is that at all how
you really lie down there and my penis
actually looks like that with little
cubes all over it there's more though oh
there's more where's the other one the
next one in title that's called come and
get me that call that
[Music]
now you should tell us the title of the
last one before we see it tell us the
title before we see I call this last one
peekaboo okay let's see peekaboo
[Applause]
Christmas card
you